do you think we'll make it
not without my team we'd do this
together
[Music]
it all happened so fast
there was a solar flare
goodbye crops and food goodbye
everything
[Music]
so i
hit
[Music]
frightened
and so alone
and i found you
[Music]
where should we have
get your elbows off the table keep your
elbows up
all right you're next
you see i'm developing something
interesting
giant leap of faith
now if you can speak
tell me something about you but the
robots must protect dog
if we don't go before that storm hits
we'll die all of us
as soon as you can walk we're leaving
one two
[Music]
head west over the mountains would you
like me to drive
don't oversteer
that's oversteer
use your foot up just a hair
perfect
[Music]
hey what's on the fuss i learned to talk
dog
i don't think it likes
me and see this
tie the rv down
hang on to something
we should be safe once we get into the
mountains those things will happen
like 150 degree heat
uv radiation
and people
hiding in the shadows
do you think we'll make it
not without my team
what we do
we do together
i believe in you this
[Music]
you